You're listening to radio lab from New York public radio, public radio,
[inaudible], c, n, n, p. R.
[inaudible].
If you want your animals Frisky, you start as early as possible.
Today's show is about animals and at six o'clock there would be crowds of people
flowing, pushing each other all over the way. Jostling,
luffing streaming towards the venue about people getting close to animals.
You have hundreds of lions and panthers, Cheetahs. You have the baboon.
You had an Indian rhinoceros
about what happens when we bring animals
into our world. The slaughter is unimaginable.
[inaudible] the crowd there is musical instruments rolling everybody. Huh?
That's Marina Belarus.
Skyah she's a historian and what she's describing is Rome 88 if you are lucky
enough to be alive then and get a seat at the Roman Colosseum on a good day,
you could watch no joke.
Hundreds of animals slaughtered right in front of your eyes, one
after the other.
All kinds of exotic creatures,
populous never knew what would take place. That was part of the agitation.
They wanted the suspense. They wanted the tension.
Alright, so now that you have that picture in your mind, consider this one.
Here we are at the Bronx Zoo,
the gorilla exhibit and what you've got her and well, no blood,
no cheap thrills, just kids,
a baby on the bed, like a piggyback ride.
Yeah, lots of kids smushing their faces to the glass,
trying to get the attention of the gorillas on the other side.
Real is aren't really noticing. But then, and this is the big moment,
one of the dumped gorillas turns around, walks to it's side of the glass and
[inaudible]
today on radio lab. We wonder how did we get here? I mean throughout history,
even before Rome, my relationship to animals is pretty simple.
We brutalized them. That's how it worked. Then in the 19th century,
someone created the zoological garden,
which wasn't much better and now we've got the zoo when we still lord over the
animals, but now we want to be their friends. We want to help them.
How did that happen and how exactly do you help an animal?
And this is an honest question when it has to spend its entire life in a cage
today on radio lab, zoos are our topic. I'm Jad Abumrad. Well you don't,
I think I take you to the very
moment in modern zoo history when the balance kind of shifted in. Who are you?
Oh, I'm Robert Krulwich and I love the zoo, but do it.
You don't know about the zoo. Kind of ICKY.
Why? I just, I want the animals to not be there.
And then gave you some somebody who's prettier, safer, safer, prettier.
I'd rather watch them on TV frankly and let them [inaudible]
let them run around the room. Well, the guy, this is interesting,
the guy who made the big move in modern zoo history. No. Hello? Hello.
His name is David Hancocks. We got him into a studio and he sorta,
he sorted a little bit like you, he, he was very ambivalent about zoos.
I'd actually for a while toyed with the idea of do I want to go and work in zoos
and try to change them or do I want to stay outside zoos and work to close them
down?
And I came to conclusion that there's no way you're gonna close who's down.
The fascination of wanting to be close to wild animals cuts across every strata
of society. You know, this is my case, by the way. I love being close to them.
Anyway, David Hancock's decided if, if you can't beat him, you join them.
And it was in the mid 1970s and David was working actually as an architect.
He was between jobs when he got a call.
A friend recommended him for a job at the woodland park zoo in Seattle. Yes,
yes. And he gets hired.
I was in an unusually fortunate situation in that just after I was hired and got
there, the zoo director left and so there was nobody to run the place.
Well except for David.
So he decided to take a look at the entire philosophy of the zoo and change
everything, starting with the gorillas
[inaudible]
awful cages. The,
the gorillas were living in a small concrete building.
It was a spare empty concrete box with a glass window. The gorillas,
of course, were bored and slowly going out of their mind.
Occasionally you'd find a gorilla who take his feces and smear it on the wall.
Yes, I'm going. I had nothing else to interact with.
The only natural components in his life that he ever came into contact with
would have been the food that he ate and the feces that he produced. So cages,
where are the problem? The solution, he decided, well,
he wanted to rip up the cages, yanked them out completely,
and replace them with, with something in natural setting of some sort.
But when he looked around for a model,
no zoo in the world had gorillas in what you'd call a natural setting.
And he wasn't even sure what is natural for, say, a gorilla. There.
There was very, very little known about gorillas, and they're wild behavior.
In fact, all the books said that gorillas don't claim,
this was early in the 70s remember? So David invited a person who didn't know.
I heard about Diane Fossey.
Diane facies work was beginning to be carried in national geographic, you know,
Fossey and yeah. From then from that Sigourney weaver movie,
she played the scrum you're playing player for,
she was played by Sigourney weaver. Diane Fossey was an actual person. Yeah,
she lived with a group of gorillas, wrote down everything.
She saw all their social interactions at all and was um,
the gorilla expert at that time.
And I heard that she was coming to the u s and she agreed to come to Seattle and
spend a couple of days with us.
We were trying to get images from her of the sort of environment we could
create. And the breakthrough came after the couple of days she'd spent with us.
I was driving her back to the airport and I said,
is there anything you seen around here or anywhere in this part of the world
that in any way resembles the sort of places where you've seen gorillas in the
wild?
And she just pointed to this verge on the freeway and I don't know what a verge
is. What's a verge avert? Oh, sorry. [inaudible] the, the,
the landscape on the side of the freeway, the sloping, what would you call it?
I would call it, if it were President Kennedy, I would call it a a not a,
what do they call it? A No. Yes and no,
but I wouldn't call it that because only president Kennedy gets out,
I would call it the green stuff on the side of the road. Okay. Yeah.
It was a banked area that had once been cleared.
And then this verdant growth that you get in Seattle was springing back and she
said, theft right there. That's where I would expect to see,
to be observing gorillas in the wild. I dropped her at the airport,
came back and on the way back illegally parked on the side of the freeway and
took photographs and then said, here, this is what day and fuss. He said,
so as you can tell, we have absolutely no idea what they were doing.
But they also didn't have a boss.
And within a few months with help from a landscape architect,
John's from Seattle, Washington, they drew up a plan and out came the balloons.
Exactly.
And we were creating huge mountains hills about 10 or 15 feet high,
some rocky cliffs, a long one, side creek cough, trees,
shrubs, about three or four feet high,
big herbs and vegetables and their angles of vines, undergrowth,
lots of Laurel Bushes, hawthorn trees. They,
comfrey leaves that we planted have long berries and pointed drip tips,
tropical like [inaudible] growing pioneer plants. Just let it grow wild.
Now nobody was watching when nobody was watching us and that that was the
critical factor, I think. Yes,
because if a traditional Zulu director had seen or heard what we were doing,
they would, he would have stopped it. And why?
Why would a traditional zookeeper have have stopped all because they were
worried about what would like,
suppose you had been a gorilla and you'd live your whole life living in a cage
in a concrete cage.
Right now I'm gonna to take you little jam my baby gorilla and stick him into a
completely new place with sky and jagged things.
I mean, I would be worried that you'd hurt yourself. I in the zoo world,
generally, I think people were nervous about
it. That's violent Sunday. She was the gorilla keeper at the Seattle's. Yes.
I was their primary keeper at that time and the zoo was advised by a lot of zoo
experts that it wouldn't work.
I had zoo directors tell me it was stupid, irresponsible,
and it was unnecessary
that, you know, the gorillas would follow the trees and hurt themselves,
climbed. They would fall on and break their necks on, break their bones,
or they'd get to putting their health at risk diseases.
They would get sick because it wasn't a sterile environment where you could,
you know, disinfect content
and that they'd get psychologically. Do you ranged from all this space?
Yes. Sometimes I'd go to David Hancock's things to say,
what are we going to do about these people? He'd say, ignore them.
A bold statement,
but as the clock tick down to the day that these five animals would walk from
their iron cage through a door into this field.
It was a real open question at the time. Well, what will happen? I think,
I think we were all somewhat nervous.
Oh, we were? We were nervous. Oh, sure. How will they react?
What will they do? The truth is nobody knew
[inaudible]
and so after five years getting ready after 16,000 square feet of guerrilla
display area, we're prepared. Finally,
it was time on this sunny July, I think as I remember, it was a July born.
I remember the exact year, I think it's seventies actually. I just looked it up.
July 31st, 1979 um, we let them out.
Kiki was the first to to come to that doorway and look out.
Kiki was the dominant gorilla of this group. There was six gorillas.
He was the star. Nikki was my favorite. I have to confess,
he was so smart and he was big. He was six feet tall,
460 pounds. He came into view first.
And of course he's never seen anything remotely like this before. So here he is,
this huge creature standing at the doorway,
just looking at this unknown world.
You stood in the doorway for many minutes
and finally Kiki's starts to slowly step forward,
first to step in another any window as far as a creek and sat down.
And then he looked up, we noticed,
he looked up for a long time and we looked up also,
and clouds were blowing by med,
fairly low altitude swallows flying over here. There were crows in the trees,
there was a wind blowing. The trees were rustling, the grass was moving.
You could see the hair on his face moving.
He looked up for a long time and took all this in and then he looked down into
the end of the water in a little there. Any,
you could see that he was looking at his face in the water,
which she'd never seen.
And then he just starts looking all around and then all of a sudden he sees us
grand violet and David and a few others were standing behind some glass at an
observation point.
They were about a hundred yards away from the doorway.
He came right up to the glass where we were and they knew that Kiki had been a
pretty angry [inaudible] before. And then he did something that, um,
we in a million years, hoped he never would,
which was to reach down into the sands,
screwed his arm down deep into the sand,
and he pulls out this big chunk of broken concrete about six to eight inches
wide. And then he held it up over his head. We thought, ah,
this is it. He's going to break the windows.
We'd spent weeks raking and telling the contractor to remove all debris and
begging them to check and recheck to look for such things as this piece of
concrete.
And there was so Kiki held it over his head and sort of waved it around a little
bit and looked with an angry look at us
and he just held it there.
[inaudible]
then he just dropped it. He almost threw it down.
He just sort of dropped it down. We all breathe a sigh of relief.
And, um,
then he laid down on his back and his mate Nina came over and sat beside him and
the little baby,
a little baby came over and laid on his chest and they just proceeded to,
uh, enjoy themselves. Like, like we weren't there.
It was magic.
It was just, it was magic.
They looked like different animals, totally different animals.
I felt like we were seeing a gorilla in the wild. Needless to say,
we all cried after he came over. I didn't cry. No. Um, but,
uh, I had a lump in my throat. I felt like finally, this is right.
This is really what's right for them.
I remember there was this strange feeling after it is almost like we'd been to a
wedding where there was this mixture of happiness and sadness and I think more
than anything else, there was just a great sense of relief.
We thought, well,
when will he produce this angry behavior and pound on the glass? And you know,
he never ever did it. The Old Kiki never returned,
never filled his body again. He was never angry anymore.
Well, I think what he's saying is that the Kiki had really changed the change in
cages, truly changed the animal here. Well,
this is an interesting science question to, to, to ask about that.
It's like if you do that,
if you take an animal and put them into a radically different environment,
how exactly does that change the animal clearly makes them feel better.
And can you measure
that? I think,
I think the closest we've come to an answer to that question is a little bit of
gold is actually done a test with primates where she's put them in different
types of enriched environments. That's Jonah Lehrer.
He's a science writer and regular radio lab contributor and what he's talking
about is a Princeton experiment. A group of scientists led by Elizabeth Ghoul,
took three groups of monkeys and put them into three different kinds of cages,
sort of like a classes and the social classes, like she divided them into a mid,
lower, a middle and an upper. Then we can go through each one.
Let's start at the top. One group of primates,
group a was in the Beverly hills of cages. Describe it.
Lots of different monkeys running around today. Lots of social interaction.
They had to forge for all their food, lots of toys. What kind of toys? You know,
squeezy toys or, or like balls I really had, it doesn't matter.
So they had lots of choices to make, lots of things to be engaged with.
Lots of conversations to have lots of stuff to occupy their mind.
And what about Group B? The middle-class Group B had, you know,
we'll call it like the uh, like the standard suburban setup.
Not too fancy that drove a Chevy. And what are we really talking about here?
They just had a bit less of everything that a few less toys,
a few less monkeys in this grand enclosure. So we can say that they had less.
Yeah, they had less than the third group was,
was kind of the standard experiments on closure, you know,
wire cage. So they had a lot less. Yeah. All right,
so you've got these three classes, monkeys, upper, middle,
lower Gould and her team put a bunch of monkeys in each class,
let them do their thing for awhile.
And then they took a few of individuals from each of these groups and looked at
their brain. So, so they looked at the,
the amount of proteins you have in your synapses,
they looked at the density of your dendritic Arbors, which, which,
which is you just say dendritic arbors. Yeah, that's fine. That's a great name.
They, they, they look botanical. Especially when they're happy. There's little,
each brain cell branches out in all kinds of different directions when it's
happy. So you get a kind of a bushy kind of a feel. Yeah, exactly.
What does that mean? If I'm an animal that good? Yeah, they think it is. I mean,
you can't exactly ask a monkey or gorilla,
are you happy you could doing okay in that cage,
but you can look at their brain cells and ask, are they branching,
are they growing and making new connections and getting full in bushy.
That's what these scientists wanted to know.
Which of the class of monkeys had the bushes, brain cells,
because those monkeys would be the ones that are most engaged with their world
most alive. Okay. Jonah. So jumping forward,
Elizabeth Gould looks into the brains of,
of individuals from each of the three classes. Yeah. And what did she find?
She found that there's a big difference between the impoverished in the middle
class. Big Difference between the part, between the bottom and the middle. Yeah.
The bottom of the middle is a big difference. How big it's,
it's very significant.
It was generally between 20% and 40% 40% bushy or brain.
Yeah. Wow.
So about the difference between the upper and the middle, did,
what was the difference there? There's almost no difference.
No difference at all. That's the weird thing between the lower and the middle.
Huge difference. Huge. But between the middle and the upper Dave,
they really couldn't find much
[inaudible]
why will I buy?
I think the lesson is at a certain point it tipping point is reached and your
brain says, okay, we're in a complex world here. We have enough toys,
we have enough social interactions. We've hit the tipping point.
Let's go full throttle. It invest in new neurons and a nice complex brain.
[inaudible]
wait, let me ask you a question.
What if you're a zoo animal and you're living in a crappy wire cage and then
they move you to a nicer one. What would happen to your brain then? Is She,
has she looked into that? Yeah,
and a, she's found that within four weeks, four weeks, about a month,
the brain itself has changed. It begins to flourish again.
And how long did it take you say four weeks. Just four weeks.
Imagine mentally like after a year? Yeah. After just four weeks,
they saw significant changes in the basic architecture of their brain.
So Robert just imagined Kiki.
Now a gorilla whose brain has been stunted by eight years of living in this
little concrete box.
Suddenly Kiki is thrust outside where the weather changes.
Birds Fly with the rain, falls from the sky or trees sway when he climbs.
Suddenly Kiki has challenges. Choices, right?
And to think that after eight years of being stuck,
his brain could explode with new activity
in just four weeks. I mean, but that makes sense. You know,
nature and nature to respond quickly. They're not going.
Most animals don't have four years to sit around and develop a complex brain.
Um, our neurons have to act fast.
The message from this research is clear from the perspective of the brain.
You can easily create a cage which allows the brain to flourish. You see,
I told, I told you that if you make the zoo better,
you can make the beasts better. This is built in zoos are not horrible. Please.
No, no. I know they are. Before we get ahead of ourselves, okay, let me just,
let me just throw one more time. Keep that in mind. Yeah.
Let me just throw one more category into our little class hierarchy here.
Okay. The category of creatures who live in the wild,
no cages. So in a sense, this is like your lab. Yep.
He's paid a visit to a guy named Fernando, not Bot.
I'm a biologist at Rockefeller University in New York, and that's where we are.
No, we're in the woods outside his lab.
We stretch for thousands of acres and he calls these woods his real life.
Let it go. So that's a chicken. That right there. Which one? Oh,
they're little teeny guys. Huh? And in the trees this fall
are his subjects.
What these birds do is in the fall they start hiding seeds or nuts throughout
the forest and they have to remember where they put them.
Winter will come on at some point, everything will be under a blanket of snow.
So have you remember where you hit the seeds?
You'll be the survivor because I mean in the case of chickadees,
whichever is small,
for them to be alive the next morning they'll have to go to sleep with a full
belly. Is that because their metabolism is so fast? Right? I mean,
they're small birds. They lose heat like mad. It's a cold night.
It's long it last 10 hours. I mean,
you got to sleep with an empty stomach the next morning you're dead.
Knowing this not bombed, didn't experiment.
He got a bunch of wild chickadees divided them into two groups. First group,
he put in a cage, pretty big cage. And by five,
by three years of like that second group set free,
they could roam the woods as they pleased over this home range of about 30
acres.
He did place bird feeders throughout the woods so they'd come back and visit.
Winter time rolls around.
The wild chickadees are out there snatching seeds from the bird feeder and
hiding them everywhere like crux or bark or crackle stone nominee hiding places
are we talking about here? I'm talking about thousands. Thousands.
That's a phenomenal memory tasks.
The cage chickadees meanwhile didn't have to remember anything cause they can
eat as many seeds as they wanted from a little trough in the cage,
not bombed at a brand comparison and what he found was in certain brain regions,
the wild chickadees had twice as many new neurons,
birth as the case ones. We're recruiting twice as many neurons as the old one,
twice, twice as many.
You know that process of replacement was moving it up much brisker pace.
His theory is that these new neurons are always showing up every day like day
laborers. The only question is, is there a job for them in the wild group?
Absolutely.
We need your help to remember where we put all those seeds in the cage group.
There's nothing for those neurons to do, but here's the sad part.
They still show up, you know, every single day.
Right. Thank you.
There's a period of a few days over which a neuron either gets a job or doesn't,
doesn't get a job, and he does. So just offs himself. Yeah.
You don't get a job. You are gone or you don't have to kill yourself.
You're just not going to get what it takes to stay alive,
which makes it all the more poignant to me. I mean, in the captives,
you've got all these new cells, they're ready to do some work. Give me a job.
Precisely. Yeah. Yeah. They'd love to do it. But it's a shrinking economy guy.
So what can I do?
Mm, mm, mm, mm, mm, mm, mm, mm,
mm, mm, mm
[inaudible].
Thanks to Fernando, not bum.
He's a biologist at Rockefeller University in upstate New York
[inaudible]
and also before him to science writer, Jonah Lehrer,
who is the author of the upcoming book, Proust, was a neuroscientist
and coming up, what does a ferocious mean?
Eating 500 pound funeral cat eat for dinner at the zoo. What,
uh, it's such a discipline. Well, no, I don't want to, I don't wanna tell you.
This is Radiolab. I'm Jad you're Robert.
And we will continue with our program on zoos.
Different Zoo. What an unusual you don't you wonder like where it comes from?
We have to get away. It used to be [inaudible] one second.
It used to be called the zoological gardens and then it got this like short
name. Yeah. Why is it a song? Let me introduce you. This is an,
I believe Mr Lou in the 1878 song called walking,
walking in the zoo.
Well, keep walking in.
People heard the song, they just couldn't think of a place in any other way.
[inaudible]
okay.